hello everyone i'm christy rizk
senior editor at genomeweb and i'll be
your moderator today
the title of today's session is critical
raw material for mrna-based vaccine
development
this ek study will start with a brief
presentation and we'll follow up with a
q a discussion with our panelist
our panelist today is ongo chiva product
manager at thermo fisher scientific
mr kojova will be speaking about the
quality requirements for critical raw
materials for commercial mrna production
and thermo fisher's offerings that
support the mrna vaccine development
process
special thanks to our sponsor thermo
fisher scientific for making this
presentation possible
mr kocheva please go ahead
christine thank having me so i'm andru
scottish and i'll shortly present our
solutions for critical raw materials
used for messenger rna-based vaccine
development
as a global leader
many steps to succeed in all of them
and reach a goal of high quality
effective vaccine
it needs high quality raw materials in
all of these steps
whether it is discovering the best
candidates for your program
doing pre-clinical in vitro or in vivo
studies
and as well in developing manufacturing
process
or even clinical trials themselves
scientific has a broad portfolio of
products that supports the entire
messenger rna vaccine development cycle
full solutions and standalone products
are available for template preparation
mrna synthesis and variable purification
and as well as vaccine formulation and
delivery
in today's presentation i will be
focusing on the amarone synthesis
step enzymes and supporting molecules
that i use here
if you have any additional questions on
this or any different stages
feel free to contact me or our company
for any
further information here you
can see a simplified manufacturing
process of hammer and avexy
it starts once a matrix plasmid is cut
using our wide selection of restriction
enzymes
and exposing the d7 promoter and gene of
interest
following this is the in vitro
transcription reaction
where the mrna molecule itself is
synthesized
the four main components here are e7 rna
polymerase
uranus inhibitor inorganic
pyrophosphates
and ntp once these are combined amarone
molecule
with the target gene is transcribed
following this is the dna template
removal
using dna's one enzyme
if the post-transcriptional capping
process is selected
during next step mrna is kept using
capping enzyme and two prime all metal
transfer rate
polyadenylic tail is added using poly a
polymer
both of these steps are needed with
stable and active amarone molecule
here our main component of the vaccine
is complete
an mrna purification and formulation
steps follows
before the vaccine is ready for use in
patients
to a product is of the highest quality
three topics
has to be mentioned product design
quality control
and manufacturing setup all of our
in-vitro transcription enzymes are
animal origin
and beta-lactam-free all the necessary
components
can be acquired together with
possibilities of customization
according to the customer need
supporting
molecules like entps and modified ntps
cap analogs are also available in
multiple forms and formats
that allow customers to use them easily
and apply them to the current process
all manufacturing is done under iso
13485
and iso 9001 certified quality
management system
tailored qc tests are used for endotoxin
tribal
endo and exonucleases as well as
functional and product specific testing
to ensure that products are made of the
highest quality
all products are manufactured in
state-of-the-art clean rooms
with ability to scale and custom
formulate fill
or package the animal origin and
beta-lactam-free products
is that they reduce the risk of asa or
bsc transmission
risk of viral agent transmission as well
as any antibiotic-related allergic
reactions
are also reduced to minimum ensuring
that final vaccine safe to use for
patients
both of these increase the safety of the
final product
and even the strict regulatory approvals
and risk assessments needed for the
release of new problem
as the supplier raw materials for
therapeutic applications
our company can ensure and provide all
necessary documentation to support this
claim
our manufacturing site is open for
orders from our customers
so you can come and see this yourself
this possible conventional manufacturing
process was reviewed
and all of the animal origin materials
were removed
a manufacturing process is free of
bacterial peptone
and beta-lactam antibiotics fermentation
steps
a perinepherol substrate is not used
during purification
and no animal origin provine serum
albumin is used for final product
formulation
the combination of controlled
environment and dedicated
equipment we can ensure our product is
safe
to use and further manufacturing of
active pharmaceutical
ingredient syringe quality control is
used
for all enzymes we manufacture we
constantly control
endo and exonucleases monitor endotoxin
and microbial contamination
no rnases can be detected in our
products so they are great fit
for use when working with rna molecules
we strive for the highest purity product
so control of protein concentration and
purity is a month
all products undergo specific activity
and functional testing to confirm
compliance to the necessary
specification
we have developed a functional qpcr
assay
to enable detection of many quantities
of contaminating dna and rna
any remaining amounts of these
impurities couldn't
interfere with further process in this
specific workflow
thus extra precautions are dating taken
during manufacturing
as well as stringent testing is done to
confirm
in maya the most important molecule in
in vital transcription direction
is nucleoside triphosphate this is the
starting material and building block of
the messenger rna
our high performing ntps and modified
entities
has purity over 99 confirmed by
hplc extensive research was done to
identify
and quantify any impurities in this
product
ensuring no critical compounds are found
these products have no biological
contaminants
thus are safe to use in vivo shelf life
of 36 months is available along all the
options
mentioned before like custom quality
controls for custom
formulation and filling sizes
and to confirm all of all of our vitro
transcription products used in this
process
are compliant with the full mentioned
specifications
these products are marked with our
therapy or grade name
here you can see a full list of products
available for this stage of the process
the therapy or grade is available only
for the product
of highest quality that were designed
with therapeutic application in mind
and passed our stringent quality control
process
with this i will conclude my short
presentation christy
i am open for any questions if there are
any
great thank you anders uh let's start
thinking um so the first question is do
you have any data on critical impurities
in ntps
yes our company has done an extensive
study on quantifying and identifying
the impurities in entities and we appear
to be ahead of the competition on this
multiple methods like mass spectrometry
and enzymatic applications were used
and we are happy to confirm that no
critical impurities are found in our
product
and do you offer any modified ntps yes
we have already provided a number of
modified entities to various customers
and we continue to look to widen our
offering
and your aof enzymes for the in vitro
transcription process
do you also offer aof restriction
enzymes for the preparation of dna
templates for in vitro transcription
yes thermo fishes scientific has already
developed one
and is currently working on a second one
to be available shortly
restriction enzymes are a huge family of
enzymes but with our technology
most of these enzymes can be made in
animal origin reform
and then finally offer any dnases with
improved activity
yes we have already developed a dna s1
variant
that is superior to the native form and
is currently being trialled by our
customers
keep an eye out for the launch of this
product or let us know if you would like
to test it now
great thank you we'll wrap it up there i
have to thank our panelists andrews
kocheva
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
thank you all for joining us for this
session